[Musique]
la fête des amis plutôt s'effacer quand
même le la soirée ou compass vraiment
avec ses meilleurs amis
ce qu'on préfère est-ce que ça compte
dans l'année la nuit du nouvel an parce
que c'est une nuit particulière c'est
une sortie comme les autres sorties
c'est peut-être une sortie comme les
autres sorties souffre le symbole qu on
y est je peux être soi même on y attache
aux mains certains symboles l'année qui
commence c'est quand même un peu
symbolique les douze coups de minuit
fatidique
si vos parents vous demander de passer
la soirée du nouvel an avec eux font le
réveillon du nouvel an c'est réservé aux
petits copains vous réguliers
quel rôle avez-vous choisi nom tout
simple
chatel princesse sophie woerth tout ça
était codé un peu dans le bain et robes
habillées
oui quand même ultra décolletée et
décolleté le nouvel an pour le nouvel an
par une robe décolletée qui fait cette
vidéo alors le décolleté de février il
ya qu'à voir le soir à 23h55 jusqu'à
minus un soir de l'événement sur des
nouvelles en mai dans la rue du klaxon
on pense en tout le monde et joyeux sur
demain c'est plutôt sabrer le champagne
ça peut être amusant mais ce le 14
juillet aussi quand une année se termine
en général moi ça pourrait plutôt me
plonger dans l'affliction
parce que on peut faire un bilan et le
bilan est en général négatif à peu près
pour tout le monde
alors moi pour l'oublier je me couche on
connaît qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette tradition de souhaiter la bonne
année aux gens a mis en relation
c'est gentil c'est gentil j'avais
toujours plaisir voir que les gens
pensent à vous et pensez un peu à elle
mais c'est un peu fastidieux vingt ans
ça peut remettre dire quelque chose de
différent dans l'escalier une fois par
an au niveau vont soit on s'en fout
totalement quoi vous n'en voyez personne
n'écarte pas d'année à des personnes de
la famille acer et sinon à des amis et
jette avec plaisir que vous envoyez les
cartes bonne année oui non pourquoi
c'est une corvée mais c'est ça j'en vois
toutes mes camarades de classe et aux
parents vous en envoyer toutes ses
autres camarades de classe pourquoi je
pense que c'est sympathique même si
elles ne répondent pas je sais que la
plupart ne répondrons pas mais c'est un
besoin d'écrire je pense je peux être
apportées sur les cartes de bonnes
années pour que l'agent n'en vois je
vois quand même pas mal non je ne sais
pas côté un peu artificielle peut-être
qu'il ne pleut pas tellement je n'aime
pas tellement souhaitée quand je sais
que c'est pas sincère je vous envoyer
des cartes de bonne année
oui beaucoup non justement je sais j'en
envoie loin possible mais ça que je les
envoie c'est ça serve et si on ne répond
pas aux voeux par ne répond pas tant pis
vous n'êtes pas sérieux
[Musique]